thank you br uh good afternoon everybody
uh my name is AEL
Garcia can you he me
there uh I am the irrigation specialist
uh as you can see here we have several
uh trials uh as regarded to
irrigation uh most of them are kind of
high-tech but uh we are looking at two
ways to provide information to our
producers uh one is the applied research
and the other one is a little bit more
basic uh the overall objective of these
projects are to study uh drought
tolerance in this case for
corn uh you might think that uh we know
everything about drug tolerant for corn
but basically what happens is that uh
Wyoming has a really unique environment
and uh and it's even much more unique if
if we come to this part of the state so
it's very dry really really very dry we
haven't had rainall at all and uh we
wonder what we should do as producers If
eventually we don't have enough water at
certain point during the growing season
so we are going to try to respond to
those things uh the much more practical
issue is related to uh water balance we
want to know how much water the crop
uses for in this environment and also we
would like to know what what is the
water use efficiency of the Corn well
how we how do we do that we do following
different uh methodologies we use uh
some things that are called crop
simulation models to support our field
research we also use what you see there
are infrared thermometers what we do
with those equipments are to measure the
temperature of the canopy and actually
when the plant is transpiring uh the
plant Co off is cooler than the
temperature of the air so those infrared
thermometers are able to measure to
determine that temperature in the canopy
the information is sent every certain
period of time
to a station that you can see there in
the middle of the experiment and Via
radio the information is sent directly
to our
office uh this work is is uh part of the
research uh of Marcelo arita he is my
PhD student soell um so he's going to
develop this project during four years
he started just now this
season this system here is a Surface
treat irrigated it's a system that we
installed this year and the reason uh
why we are using treat irrigation for
corn here is mostly because we need to
know exactly the amount of water that we
are applying to the crop so so by having
this system we can do that very easy and
uh if you need to know a little bit more
about the specifics of that you should
ask Marcelo he's the one that is running
all the programs in his computer that
just comes from time to time to his
office and see whether or not everything
is okay sometimes actually he corrects
me and uh what else
uh as uh Dr has said we have several
experiments similar to this one and this
is on the surface trip we have another
one over there is the subsurface DP and
we have a third one far away there in in
the sprinkler
system one of the Practical results
we've gotten so far is that for example
we
compared uh yield of corn produced on
these systems with the flooded one uh in
terms of yield we got pretty much the
same but the water use efficiency of
this irrigation systems is really very
high for the crops is very high and uh
we were able to reduce the amount of
water that the crop needs in more than
four times I mean 25% of the water that
we are using uh 25% of the water we use
uh in a flooded irrigation is the one we
are using here at most so as you can see
the crop looks really very healthy and
we are expecting this year to have even
even a little bit more y than the other
uh irrigation
systems uh this is what I have for you
in this first stop uh if you have any
questions please uh feel
free yes sir
nit nitrogen rate I don't remember
Marcel I think we
app here was kind of
150 almost pounds per
acre 150 pounds per acre yeah
any other
question have you had any trouble with
these hoses clogging up with weeds well
it's uh first time and this is on
Surface uh I don't think we will have
problems right now uh it's first year I
mean from uh moss and such in the
irrigation water no we don't do know
it's from a well yeah it's from a well
yeah yeah good for you thank you so you
might just tell the other trailer what
the question was excuse me what was the
question
oh uh the question was whether or not we
have some problems with clogging
emitters here due to uh WS or something
like that but the water is a is a well
water so it's no problem so
far any other
question is there any plan certainly
water use efficiency is one of the
budgets budgets that you're looking at
what about the economics of of this
system compared to Conventional uh Mike
moris as asking about the economics of
this as compared to Conventional uh we
don't have yet of course it's first year
but we plan to we plan to to look at
that as
well thank you sure yes sir the I think
the well maybe it's uh cold than the
natural water uh is there difference the
well water and the natural water yes the
quality uh mainly to the to the uh Co
production yes well there is one thing
here we don't get rainfall at all
hopefully we don't we won't get today
but we don't get rainall at all the corn
approximately needs 400 MM the whole
season divide by 25 it gives you inches
uh here if you do not irrigate you don't
produce actually yeah but uh the
difference in water rainfall or well
water is mainly the quality yeah
rainfall is much better
than we were the difference I mean the
difference to the production oh
production
well no I don't know I don't know but
probably there is not a huge
difference yes Iration test yes but uh
we shouldn't have too much difference uh
the question here is whether or not
there are differences in yield with uh
rainfall water or well water no no R
that's uh the natural water natural
water yes CH water canal oh Canal water
okay differen is between uh ditch water
and uh yeah well water well the the main
the main difference is quality still Yes
quality and the the temperature of
course yes temperature as well